MUSICAL PHYSICAL >> Jesse: THE
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE SET TO START VERY
SOON.
MOCKING THE PRESIDENT AMID THE
DEADLY PANDEMIC AND EVEN TOUTING
THE FACT THAT AMERICA HAS THE
MOST CASES IN THE WORLD.
A CORRESPONDENT FOR "GQ"
MAGAZINE TWEETED OUT, WHO IS THE
S-WHOLE COUNTRY NOW?"
THE U.S. IS FOUR TIMES IN
POPULATION FOR CASES OF
CORONAVIRUS.
LEVERAGED SAYS IT "THE
CORONAVIRUS IS NOW THE AMERICAN
VIRUS."
IN THOSE INSULTS AND APPARENTLY
INSPIRING HILLARY CLINTON TO
TWEET "HE DID PROMISE AMERICA
FIRST."
>> Greg: I CAN’T BELIEVE I’M
SAYING THIS BUT THERE ARE NO
WORDS FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
SHE DEFINITELY STOLE THE JOKE
AND IT’S NOT EVEN A GOOD JOKE
AND IT’S BASED ON THE SUFFERING
OF OTHERS.
I WOULD SAY SHE SHOULD ROT IN
BUT I THINK SHE’S ALREADY THERE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT PEOPLE
SUFFERING -- BY THE WAY THE
INFECTION RATES ARE INCREASING
BECAUSE WE ARE TESTING MORE AND
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT REALLY
WANTED MORE TESTING SO YOU WILL
ACTUALLY SEE MORE INFECTION
RATES.
IF YOU SEE THAT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DIRECT ATTENTION
TO YOURSELF ON SOCIAL MEDIA, YOU
ARE WHAT SCIENTISTS WOULD CALL A
SCUMBAG AND YOU ARE SOMEBODY
THAT WE WILL NOT FORGET WHEN
THIS IS ALL OVER AND DONE WITH.
YOU DON’T WANT TO SAY WHO ARE
THE HEROES AND WHO ARE THE
VILLAINS NOW, WE WILL HAVE
PLENTY OF TIME FOR THAT LATER.
SHE’S GOING TO FALL ON THE BILL
INSIDE AND I’M NOT GOING TO
FORGET IT.
I THOUGHT I COULD STOP TALKING
ABOUT HER BUT I’M GOING TO CHASE
HER FOR THE REST OF HER LIFE.
>> Dana: HER TWEET TO ME WAS
JUST LIKE SO SUPER
IRRESPONSIBLE.
COMPARE THAT TO FORMER
SECRETARY JOHN KERRY ’TS TWEET
TODAY ABOUT CONGRESSMAN MASSIE
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP ACTUALLY
RETWEETED AND SAID, I ACTUALLY
AGREE WITH YOU, THAT WAS PRETTY
FUNNY.
I WISH I COULD REMEMBER THE NAME
OF THE WRITER BUT ON NATIONAL
REVIEW.COM THERE’S A PIECE
ABOUT CHINA TODAY THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT.
IF YOU ARE A JOURNALIST AND YOU
CARE ABOUT FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND
OF THE RIGHT OF JOURNALISTS THEN
YOU SHOULD ACTUALLY REALLY BE
EXPOSING WHAT CHINA IS DOING AND
YOU SHOULD BE VERY CLEAR THAT
THESE ARE THE REPORTED CASES IN
AMERICA.
WE KNOW THAT CHINA IS NOT
TELLING THE TRUTH, WE KNOW THAT.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE THE
JOURNALISTS ARE THROWN OUT.
THEY ARE TREATED LIKE AND THEY
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHO WAYS TO
USE EMOJIS TO GET AROUND THE
SENSORS.
THE OTHER THING IS I READ A
REPORT TODAY ABOUT HOW CHINA HAS
SENT ALL OF THESE TESTS TO SPAIN
AND ITALY AND ELSEWHERE TO HELP
THEM AND THE TESTS ARE
DEFECTIVE.
SO HOW CAN WE POSSIBLY TRUST THE
NUMBERS THAT ARE COMING OUT OF
CHINA?
THE OTHER REASON THAT THE
NUMBERS ARE NOT SO BAD IN CHINA
RIGHT NOW IS BECAUSE THEY
STOPPED TESTING AND THEY DON’T
CARE ABOUT THEIR PEOPLE.
WE DO.
WE ARE HONEST ABOUT OUR NUMBERS.
WE ARE TRANSPARENT ABOUT IT AND
WE SHOULD CELEBRATE THAT AND NOT
TRY TO RUB IT IN PRESIDENT TRUMP
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S FACE BECAUSE
WE ARE ACTUALLY BEING HONEST.
A >> Jesse: WHEN THEY TRY TO
RUB IT IN TRUMP’S FACE, THEY
ACTUALLY RUB IT IN AMERICA’S
FACE.
EMILY, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Emily: THESE GUYS ARE LIKE
STUCK IN A COMIC BOOK.
TO HIS POINT, TRUMP WILL NO
MATTER WHAT ALWAYS BE THE
VILLAIN.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
COMIC BOOK AND REAL LIFE IS NOT
REAL LIFE IS A REAL LIFE SO HE
CAN MAKE GOOD DECISIONS WITH
POSITIVE OUTCOMES WHICH WE ARE
SEEING IN THIS RESPONSE.
DR. FAUCI SAID HE IS WORKING
CLOSE TOGETHER AND DR. BURKS IS
TAMPING DOWN HYPERBOLIC
STATISTICS AND PREDICTIONS TO
TRY TO CALM PEOPLE’S FEARS, BUT
THERE’S NO WAY THAT THE MEDIA IS
GOING TO COVER IT AND THERE’S
CERTAINLY NO WAY THAT
HILLARY CLINTON NOR EVERYONE
ELSE IN THOSE MEDIA FIGURES ARE
GOING TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT
WHATSOEVER.
>> Jesse: JUAN, BILL AND
HILLARY DID SEND THOUSANDS OF
PIZZAS TO FIRST RESPONDERS HERE
SO YOU HAVE TO GIVE HER CREDIT
FOR THAT.
>> Juan: I THINK A LOT OF THIS
IS FACETIOUS BEHAVIOR BUT I
DON’T THINK IT’S APPROPRIATE, I
THINK IT’S REPREHENSIBLE ON SOME
LEVELS BECAUSE WE JUST DON’T
NEED IT RIGHT NOW.
MY POINT HERE WOULD BE, WHEN
THEY SAY THE UNITED STATES IS
NUMBER ONE, I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE, I DON’T KNOW THAT WE
CAN TRUST CHINA’S NUMBERS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WAS
TALKING WITH THE CHINESE NUMBER
TO MAKE A LEADER LAST NIGHT AND
I DON’T KNOW IF HE ASKED HIM,
CAN WE GET THE ACTUAL NUMBERS
AND KNOW WHERE THINGS ARE?
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE ARE USING
MODELS FROM ITALY AND YOU ARE
EUROPE BUT CHINA WAS WAY AHEAD
OF THAT.
WE COULD HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW WE DEAL WITH THE CYCLES, THE
RISE IN THE FALL AND THE SPIKES
IF CHINA WOULD ACTUALLY BE
HONEST WITH US AND I DON’T THINK
THEY’VE BEEN HONEST.
I THINK THAT SHOULD BE THE FOCUS
HERE, THAT KIND OF MODELING
COULD HELP US WITH WHAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH AT THE MOMENT.
THE FACETIOUS COMMENTS, SOME OF
THEM ARE OVER THE LINE BUT I
DON’T THINK IT’S WORTH THE TIME.